こんにちは
料理研究家のハジ・メン・ＳＡＷＲＥだ
みんなはタコライス食べたことあるかな？
タコライスそう、それはね
多分なんですけども
沖縄の郷土料理みたいな沖縄で有名な料理なんですけども
僕もね何回か食べたことあるんです
それはめちゃくちゃおいしい
もう、大好きで
タコライスってのががメニューあるとまず頼んじゃうくらい
タコライスが好きなんだけども
私としたことが、タコライスの作り方が わからない
まるで、さっぱりさ
そもそもタコを使うかどうかもわかんないし
どうやてタコライスとゆうものを作ってるかわからないですけども、
まあ！僕くらいの 天才の料理家になるともうね、
想像と知識だけで
タコライスを作れると思ってみてるんで
今日は何も見ず何も参考にせず
僕の感性だけでタコライスを作ってみようと思います
なに、美食家だから安心してくれ
タコライスに使えそうな素材を用意しました
ケチャ　ごはん　たまｇ・・・
なんかトマトが入ってたんですよね
トマト　半額でした　ルッコラ　eeg
海苔もねパラパラっと
入ってた気がします
うぅーーーーーーー
タコです
っはい！というわけで今回は
こちらの食材を使って
私
タコライスを自分で作ってみようと思います
マジで何も知りません
レッツ　クッキング！
ウグェ
先ほども見せたように、こちらで作って行こうと思います
マジなんもわかんねーな
ひとまず、ビート板じゃねぇや、まな板を洗いましょう
まな板を洗ったら先ず取りあえず、タコ刻みます
え～うぁ～　これさぁ
魚介類で料理を、まずした事が無いし
なんかプルプルしてるし
う、ぅわわわ、マジヤバい、マジヤバい
う～マジか、本物だ、凄い、タコです。
ﾜｰやばいやばい、なんか吸盤の感じが生々しい
うわぁやばいよ
水で洗いましょう
うわっまじか　うわっうわっ　うわぁーあ
ちょっと待て
待って、俺触れねーわ、触れない　　だって、動いたりしないよね？
うわぁ待って　うぅ　うわ、じゃもう切ります
食べやすいサイズに切って行きます。タコを・・・
ぅわ、マジか、わーやだなー
ぅわ！も～ぞわぞわして来た
や、やるしかねんだ
いただきます！わー取れた！・・・いやそれは取れるわ
まあまあ、意外と切ってみたら、切ってみたら意外とすんなりかも。
けっこう生々しいな。大ジョブそうだな、よし、よし、よし、
はい、タコカット完了しました
タコのカットが出来たので、ここからはライスの準備
早速ライスを作っていくよ
ではご飯だ。
炊飯器を使いまっしょう！
オープンッ
ここで、ライスの出番だ、これは多分無洗米？
れこは無洗米なので多分、洗わなくていいヤツです
え？待って。洗ってないから無洗米？　洗ってあるから無洗米？
え、どうゆうこと？どっちだろう、無洗米って洗わなくていいっじゃないっけ？
無洗米ってどっちだ？
無　洗　米　。　洗ってないお米だから、洗わなくて良いお米？
どっちだ
多分、大丈夫っしょ
おぉ、オッケーオッケー　入りました。
ん？
あ、まって！まって！落ち着け落ち着け！　取り消し。
違う違う！　取り消し。
違う違う違う違う違う
お米を炊く準備が出来たので
このまま作るとこなんですけども
ここにもうタコごと入れまーす
これで一石二鳥ですね。
よく分かんないですけども
タコとゆでる事が出来ます。
オーケイ！では
はい、これでお米炊くのしばし待ちます。
炊ける前に、トマトとか野菜とかの準備をしていきましょう
いくぜぃ
まずトマトを洗いまぁす
なんかね。入ってた気がするんすよ、トマトは。
まったく勘だけどね。
大体でいーんだよね。大体。
もうまって、ぐっちゃぐちゃだー
オーケイ
大体これくらいだったらいいと思います。
これも適当に水洗いして、ちょびっと切ります。
きたーーー
炊けたみたいです。
なんか、これぐらいの野菜はのっていた気がする。
本題は、炊飯器のタコがどうなってるかなんすよ。
オープン
おぉ、わ、あ、ぽいぽいぽい
あ　あ　あ　あ　まて、タコの匂いはする
どうすかね
タコ飯みたいな感じまでは来ました。
これ成功じゃね？
いけるぞ。いけるいける。
これは作れるぞ！
これは作れる！
落ち着こう。
１回フライパンにご飯をよそいます。
ご飯、僕が食べるくらい分とります。
なんかね、ケチャップをかけた気がするんですよ
こっから分かんないけど、
ケチャップをかけて、色を付けた気がする
色的には、結構濃くなってきました。
もう盛りつけましょう。
ひとまずご飯をこっちに移します。
ベースは完成なんすよ、ぶっちゃけ。
トマトをのせて、
葉っぱのせて、
海苔は違うな。
んじゃ、卵
バーンとのせればー
完成！
ハイ、というわけで、完成しました。
俺特製のタコライス
ﾁｭﾁｭ ﾌﾞﾛﾛｫｫﾝ ﾄﾞｩﾝ
問題は味の方ですよ
これが正しい作り方かどうかも分かんないですけども
なんかね大体こんな感じだった気がする
で、しっかり混ぜるんすよ
味をしっかりこう、ね。
いや、いい感じだと思いますよ。
では早速食べてみましょう。
いただきます。
ん？
なに？
んー？！
コレッ
美味しくない。
赤飯をイタリアの人用に作った味がしました。
あ、肉を使うんだね
あ、けどケチャップは使うよ
醤油も使うし
チリソース、塩コショウ
あ、トマトもあってる。
チーズがいるのか。
なんか、チーズと肉が足りなかったみたいですね。
俺、何作ってたんだｗ
ちょっとねまた機会があればまた自分で作ってみようと思います。
じゃあな